В ефірі випуск новин «heute 19 Uhr» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір та ласкаво просимо
до перегляду актуальних новин.
Норберт Леман знає більше про новини спорту.
Вітаю!
Теми випуску:
Залишилися лічені години до початку
кризового саміту G7.
У баварському замку Ельмау лідери провідних
індустріальних країн шукатимуть рішення.
Новий дует на чолі Лівих.
Джанін Вісслер і Мартін Шірдеван шукатимуть
шляхи подолання кризи партії.
Лауреатом Німецької кінопремії
стає фільм жанру драма «Дорогий Томас».
Кінострічка отримала дев'ять відзнак «Лола»,
зокрема, у категорії  «Найкращий художній фільм».
Канцлер вже готовий зустрічати гостей,
а найвпливовіший гість - президент США -
вже в дорозі
на, можливо, найважливіший саміт G7 в історії.
Під час саміту країни обговорять подальші кроки
боротьби з російською агресією.
Після анексії Криму, вісім років тому,
президента Росії
було виключено з учасників саміту.
До складу G7 входять Японія, Канада,
США, Великобританія, Франція,
Італія та Німеччина.
Спільно їхні економічні показники становлять
майже третину світової економіки.
Керівники держав та урядів,
а також очільники ЄС
зустрінуться в громаді Гарміш-Партенкірхен,
у замку Ельмау.
Навколо розкішного курорту є зона безпеки.
16-ти кілометрова зона перекриття,
задіяно 18 тисяч поліцейських.
Початок - завтра. Репортаж Андреаса Кюнаста.
Канцлер Шольц вперше прийматиме
високопосадовців на міжнародному саміті.
Ось він в кадрі - біла пляма в третьому вікні.
Німеччині випала нагода організовувати саміт G7,
темою якого є актуальні кризові питання.
У випуску «Kanzler kompakt»
Шольц звертається до німців.
Ельмау знаходиться в горах.
Гори зрушити ми точно не зможемо,
проте прийняти важливі й корисні рішення
нам, безумовно, до снаги.
За умови нашої єдності та рішучості.
Винуватцем кожної теми розмови
Великої сімки на саміті
є дехто восьмий - Путін.
Війна Путіна проти України,
посилення глобальної продовольчої кризи,
як її наслідок,
а також боротьба зі змінами клімату
на задньому плані.
Ніби на доказ цього РФ сьогодні опублікувала
ці відеокадри та повідомила про ракетні обстріли
всієї території України.
Росія демонструє військову і політичну силу.
Президент Путін під час зустрічі
з президентом Лукашенком
погоджує поставку «Іскандерів» Білорусі,
які можуть бути носіями ядерних боєголовок.
Несподіваний саміт G2 у Санкт-Петербурзі.
На саміті G7 спробує вкотре відкрити очі
на критичність ситуації,
особливо країнам Азії та Африки.
Занадто багато країн досі переконані,
що економічні проблеми,
спричинені «європейською» війною,
їх не стосуються.
Таким чином зростає тиск на народ України
погодитися на «поганий» мир.
Наразі всі сім представників прямують до Баварії.
В такому ж складі, лише всімох, вони проведуть
перший день саміту.
А у понеділок очікують гостей
з Південної Америки, Азії та Африки.
Тео Коль, тож яке значення має цей саміт?
Критики кажуть,
що склад G7 давно вже не є актуальним.
Це справді так.
Критики мають рацію.
Країни G7 становить 30% глобальної економіки,
натомість населення їх лише 10%.
Тож це радше клуб заможних, які представляють
інтереси все меншої кількості людей.
Але G7 знають про цю проблему.
Канцлер запросив представників
п'яти великих країн, серед яких Індія та Індонезія.
Їх планують підкупити, щонайменше цими
ідилічними ландшафтами замку Ельмау.
Адже багато хто з них ще досі не визначився
в протистоянні систем,
до прикладу, між Росією та Китаєм з одного боку
та G7 з іншого.
Тож це також боротьба за цінності.
Більш ніж половина населення світу -
це громадяни тих країн,
які досі не засуджують війну РФ.
Я думаю, що актуальна критика
не відтворює всього масштабу кризи, яка охоплює
продовольчу кризу, енергетику та клімат.
З огляду на актуальну ситуацію,
кожний додатковий голос - це вже перемога.
З нами в студії був Тео Коль,
наживо з Ельмау, Баварія.
На відстані 100 кілометрів
від місця проведення саміту - у Мюнхені -
сьогодні зібралися 15 обʼєднань,
які виступають проти глобалізації.
Вони закликали приєднуватися до мітингів
проти саміту.
Девіз: «Cправедливість виглядає інакше».
Та все ж долучилося менше людей,
ніж очікувалося.
Репортаж Александра Поеля.
Це тільки деякі з гасел.
Та лунали вони не так гучно, як очікувалося.
Організатори розраховували на 20 тисяч учасників.
Насправді ж долучилося 4-6 тисяч осіб.
Наразі багато людей сумніваються,
чи варто зараз виходити на вулиці
і боротися за кліматичну
та соціальну справедливість,
а також проти тих,
хто зараз прямує на саміт в Ельмау,
чи навпаки варто навіть підтримати їх
у питанні війни в Україні.
Прихильники останньої думки також тут.
І хоча вони всім серцем виступають
проти озброєння,
проте вимагають надати Україні більше зброї.
Ми сподіваємося, що війна завершиться,
Путіна вийде зупинити.
Та ми переконані, що для цього
Україні потрібно більше важкої зброї.
На мітингу зібралися захисники клімату,
противники глобалізації і критики капіталізму.
Їх всіх об’єднує скептицизм щодо саміту G7,
який розпочнеться завтра вранці у замку Ельмау.
Йдеться перед усім про більшу справедливість.
На мою думку, було б доречно,
якби до саміту долучилися також інші країни,
як от з Півдня.
Багатьох турбує кліматична криза та політика,
яка не достатньо швидко на неї реагує.
Ми хочемо бачити зміни.
Щонайменше, щоб реалізували те, що вже ухвалили.
Як от пункти Паризької угоди.
Загалом демонстрації пройшли мирно.
Тільки наприкінці не минуло без сутичок з поліцією.
Про актуальні події
напруженого та доленосного саміту
у Верхній Баварії
ми розповідаємо на нашій сторінці «ZDFheute»
та у прямому ефірі.
Два дні тому Україна стала кандидатом
на вступ до ЄС.
Тепер президент Зеленський заявив,
що допоможе Грузії
на її шляху до Європейського Союзу.
Минулого вечора в Грузії десятки тисяч людей
вийшли відстояти своє бажання приєднатися до ЄС.
Вони вважають,
що їх влада зробила недостатньо для того,
щоб країна отримала статус кандидата.
Нещодавно спільноту сколихнули відеорозмови
європейських бургомістрів
з фальшивим Віталієм Кличко.
Меру Берліна Францисці Ґіффай зателефонував
чоловік, який виглядав і говорив так, як мер Києва.
Підозру викликали його дивні запитання.
Очевидно, це було ретельно сфальсифіковане відео,
так званий діпфейк.
Поки невідомо, хто за цим стоїть.
Перейдемо до зʼїзду партії Лівих.
Джанін Вісслер отримує другий шанс.
Жительку Гессену вкотре обрали на посаду
керівника партії,
хоча постать 41-річної пані досить суперечлива:
декілька поразок на виборах
і внутрішньопартійна боротьба.
Її колега -
депутат Європарламенту Мартін Ширдеван.
Репортаж з Ерфурта Карла Гінтерляйтнера.
Коли Карл Маркс говорив, що потрібні зміни,
то він мав на увазі весь світ.
Керівник партії Лівих має на увазі власну партію.
З нагоди 15-річчя партії засновник партії Ґреґор Ґізі
звернувся з особливим привітанням.
На наше 15-річчя мені не спадає на думку
жодне привітання,
бо наразі ми знаходимося в екзистенційній кризі.
Ми всі маємо це розуміти.
Багато незрозумілого залишається у партії Лівих,
зокрема, ставлення партії до війни в Україні.
Опівдні вирішальний момент для Джанін Вісслер,
яка з одного боку виступає проти поставок зброї,
але визнає неправомірність дій Росії.
Та все ж позиція залишається суперечливою.
Ми маємо засуджувати війну Росії проти України
без жодних «якщо» й «але».
Таким чином
Вісслер завойовує голоси виборців
та стає очільником партії з 57,5%.
А це майже на 30% менше, ніж минулого разу.
Її колега, кандидат Мартін Ширдеван,
отримує 61% голосів.
Попри гучні вітання
приблизно половина партії не підтримує такий дует.
Все ж Мартін Шірдеван налаштований оптимістично.
Ми чітко зрозуміли сигнал. Ми знову тут.
І це той сигнал,
яким партія ділиться з усіма громадянами.
Незрозуміло, чи такий сигнал виконає свою місію.
Поки суперечки в межах партії затихли.
Примирення все ж не відбулося.
Ральф Шумахер наживо з Ерфурта.
Чи зможуть нові очільники врятувати партію з кризи?
Щонайменше Джанін Вісслер
відчайдушно боролася
за свою політичну діяльність та існування партії.
Вона ризиковано вдалася до теми дебатів
з українського питання. Хоча традиційно
Ліві є дружніми до Росії і противниками НАТО.
Вісслер отримує ідеального кандидата в партнери
в особі Мартіна Шірдевана,
політика, орієнтованого на реформи, стратега.
Хоча на федеральному рівні він є ще мало відомим.
Це подвійне керівництво прагне відродити Лівих
у якості опозиції до «Світлофорної» коаліції,
підбадьорюючи себе і демонструючи єдність.
Сара Вагенкнехт виступала проти Вісслер,
але була відсутня через хворобу.
Чи стане цей новий тур новим центром сили Лівих,
який покладе кінець міжпартійним суперечкам
та скандалам, пов'язаним з сексизмом,
та визначить партійний напрямок -
питання абсолютно відкрите. Але воно має
вирішальне значення для майбутнього партії.
Вони поставили перед собою певні цілі -
CDU і Зелені в Північному Рейні-Вестфалії.
Країна має стати прикладом для Європи,
об'єднавши захист клімату
та розвиток промисловості.
Сьогодні з'їзди партій майбутніх партнерів
схвалили коаліційну угоду, а у вівторок
прем'єр-міністра Вюста
буде переобрано в парламенті землі.
Лідер партії Зелених Північного Рейну-Вестфалії
Нойбаур має стати суперміністром
з питань економіки, клімату та енергетики.
Про це повідомляє Дорте Фербер.
Хендрік Вюст прийнятий з оплесками у Бонні.
Він привів свою партію CDU NRW
до перемоги на виборах,
а тепер просуває коаліційну угоду з Зеленими.
Сьогодні я можу сказати,
що фундамент для успішної роботи
Північного Рейну-Вестфалії
закладено на наступні п'ять років.
Нас об'єднує одне:
Ми хочемо зробити Північний Рейн-Вестфалію
першим кліматично нейтральним
промисловим регіоном Європи.
Коаліційну угоду схвалили
переважною більшістю голосів.
З 600 делегатів - лише чотири «проти».
CDU залишає за собою сферу внутрішньої безпеки
та несе відповідальність за освітню політику.
У питаннях внутрішньої безпеки, шкіл та освіти,
а також у гармонії економіки та екології,
я вважаю, що два партнери по коаліції
мають шанс на хорошу співпрацю.
У Білефельді також тріумфують:
Лідерка партії Мона Нойбаур
принесла Зеленим найкращий результат
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії за всю історію.
Але «чорно-зелена» коаліція зустрічає опір
з боку Зеленої молоді.
Робота з переконаннями:
Нам також вдалося досягти того,
що на наступних державних виборах у землі всі,
кому виповнилося 16 років, зможуть
взяти участь у цьому торжестві демократії.
Право голосу з 16 років,
не менше ніж 1000 метрів відстані
для вітрових турбін.
Незважаючи на проєкти,
до питання видобутку бурого вугілля,
як і раніше, ставляться скептично.
Таким чином ця коаліційна угода завдає
кліматичному руху удару у спину
в найважливіших темах.
Батько Олівера Крішера, міністр довкілля
Північного Рейну-Вестфалії, налаштований інакше.
Він виходить з карантину
для укладання коаліційної угоди.
У результаті угода і тут отримає більшість у 85%.
«Чорно-зеленій» коаліції
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії бути.
У столиці Норвегії Осло загинули 2 особи
та понад 20 отримали поранення
внаслідок нападу на гей-бар минулої ночі.
Поліції вдалося затримати імовірного злочинця -
норвежця з іранським корінням.
Органи влади підозрюють,
що він ісламістського походження.
Норвегія встановила найвищий рівень
терористичної загрози.
Прайд-парад, запланований
на сьогодні, було скасовано.
Проте багато людей вийшли на вулиці,
щоб провести демонстрацію
на захист прав квір-спільноти.
Вчора на прикордонній огорожі
іспанського ексклаву
Мелілья в Марокко відбувся фатальний штурм.
Тим часом ЗМІ повідомляють
щонайменше про 18 загиблих.
Близько 2000 біженців намагалися
потрапити на територію ЄС.
Також десятки охоронців було поранено.
Марокко звинуватило мігрантів
у застосуванні насильства.
З іншого боку, місцева правозахисна організація
звинуватила правоохоронні органи
в жорсткому поводженні з мігрантами.
Тепер до Берліна:
Коли 1700 режисерів збираються разом,
то «Лола» не за горами.
«Лола» - це найважливіша
і найпрестижніша нагорода
в німецькій кіноіндустрії.
Гості насолодилися спілкуванням
і відзначили головний фільм-переможець.
З Берліна Себастьян Горскі.
Маючи дванадцять номінацій,
вони, творці фільму «Дорогий Томас»,
вважалися великими фаворитами вечора,
і вони не були розчаровані.
Золота «Лола» дістається продюсерам
фільму «Дорогий Томас».
Золоту «Лолу» за найкращий ігровий фільм
отримав портрет письменника Томаса Браша.
Неоднозначний, бунтівний, непристосований,
зіграний Альбрехтом Шухом, який був відзначений
як найкращий виконавець головної ролі.
Я дуже приголомшений, інакше не скажеш.
Я хотів би обійняти Томаса Браша,
я уявляю це собі.
Нагороду за найкращу головну жіночу роль
отримала Мельтем Каптан
за роль у драмі «Рабіє Курназ проти Джорджа Буша»-
справжньої історії ув'язненого
Гуантанамо Мурата Курназа
та боротьби його матері за його визволення.
Для мене це важливо, тому що...
Взагалі я народилася і виросла в Німеччині.
Німецькі фільми сформували мою особистість,
це моя культура.
Вечір, повністю присвячений німецькому кіно,
і чіткий сигнал про те, що індустрія продовжує
підтримувати сильні фільми,
створені в Німеччині, незважаючи на пандемію.
А тепер Норберт про спорт, а саме
про фінал в Берліні, чемпіонат Німеччини
з 14 видів спорту.
Більше половини зі 190 найменувань
були відзначені нагородами.
Сьогодні особливо цікавим є
жіночий триатлонний спринт.
Захоплююча дуель
між Аннікою Кох та Лаурою Ліндеманн,
яка здобула свій третій чемпіонський титул.
Жінка з Постдама випереджає
на 9 секунд Аніку Кох
після 750 м плавання, 20 км велогонки і 5 км бігу.
Таким чином, Ліндеманн кваліфікувалася
на чемпіонат Європи в Мюнхені у серпні.
Торбен Йоханнесен та Ніколас Шредер
виграли титул у двійці без екіпажу.
Йоханнесен/Шредер перемогли Лаурітса Фоллерта
та Джуліана Гарта,
колег по команді
з німецької вісімки у фіналі на Шпреї.
Сара Восс з Кельна здобула
свій другий титул у Берліні.
Після вчорашньої перемоги в багатоборстві
вона виграла і в опорному стрибку,
випередивши Каріну Шенмаєр та Лону Хакер.
Тепер подивімося на змагання з легкої атлетики.
Стрибок з жердиною Бо Канда Літа Баере
здобув титул і поставив знак оклику
на міжнародних змаганнях,
показавши результат 5,90 метра.
Бо Канда Літа Баере покращив
свій попередній рекорд на 9 см.
Щоправда, між 23-річним спортсменом
та планкою для стрибків з жердиною,
було не так багато повітря, але з цими 5,90 м
зараз він - третій у світі
та кандидат на медалі
на майбутніх чемпіонатах світу та Європи.
Це стосується і метання диска: Крістін Пуденц
кинула свій диск до 67,10 м,
що на 32 см далі, ніж було до цього.
Це її четвертий титул чемпіона Німеччини.
Цим шляхом йде і спринтер Джина Люкенкемпер,
яка легко виграла свій півфінал на дистанції 100 м
і впевнено вийшла у вечірній фінал з часом 11,29.
До речі, Джина Люкенкемпер буде гостею
програми «Aktuellen Sportstudio»
сьогодні ввечері о 23:00,
а завтра фінал у Берліні в прямому ефірі
на ZDF з 10:15.
На чемпіонаті світу з плавання в Будапешті
Флоріан Веллброк не зміг захистити свій титул
на дистанції 1500 метрів.
Чемпіоном світу став італієць Грегоріо Палтріньєрі,
який очолив гонку з самого початку
та здобув впевнену перемогу.
Між Веллброком та Боббі Фінком
розгорнулася захоплююча боротьба за друге місце,
яку виграв американець.
А Лукас Мартенс з Магдебурга зайняв 4 місце.
Це всі новини зі спорту.
Озден Терлі розповість нам,
де завтра світитиме сонце,
а де будуть грози.
Марієтта Сломка запрошує вас до перегляду
випуску «heute journal» о 23:15.
Дякуємо за перегляд, до побачення.
Будемо раді, якщо ви доєднаєтеся
до перегляду завтра, гарного вечора.
Доброго вечора і ласкаво просимо
до перегляду прогнозу погоди.
Завтра і наступні кілька днів
очікуються стійкі погодні умови.
Це пов'язано з цим циклоном,
який майже не рухається.
А у антициклонів немає вибору.
Вони повинні рухатися на північ,
ухилятися від струменевого потоку,
який також рухається далеко на північ.
Це приносить гаряче повітря
з Північної Африки до Скандинавії.
Наступної ночі на сході країни
ще пройдуть зливи та грози.
Їх меншатиме, з’являтимуться нові,
і вони в основному будуть зосереджені
на заході Німеччини.
Температура опуститься до 17°
наприклад, на північному сході.
Там температура близько 11°,
наприклад, у Фогтланді,
але на решті території південного сходу - нижче 15°.
Завтра протягом дня очікуються нові грози
на південному заході,
на заході і до Балтійського моря.
Крім того, вони можуть принести зливи.
На інших територіях сонячно,
температура повітря сягатиме 33°,
часто значення близько 30°,
дещо прохолодніше на заході - 22°.
В понеділок новий штормовий фронт
прийде до нас із заходу,
температура становитиме до 35°, гарного вечора.